[Music]
welcome back
to next episode of what's up prof hello
walter
how are you doing today no i'm doing
very well and you
thank you i'm doing just fine yes
can you open up for us through the world
of friends absolutely
our heavenly father without you
we can do nothing
and you have given us so many
instructions and
so much wisdom in all your writings and
your word
and you must help us please to delve
into your word so that we might find the
answers that you have hidden for us
there
give us wisdom may your angels protect
us and may we be readied as a people for
your soon coming
is my prayer in jesus name amen
amen
today we have to look at a few questions
and comments again that we've
received over the past few weeks
because we don't get to everything
all the questions but we try and get to
most of them
i see many of the people ask questions
and then other people answer for them
that helps that helps a lot yes that's
very nice and thank you by the way for
all the very nice comments
and thank you also for keeping us on our
toes with the
critical questions and comments
questions
yes also thank you to our members
yes we appreciate all the people that
watch
what's up prof yes there was a
statement by one of the viewers that the
oil fields that you mentioned that can
rapidly form
um he stated that
oil is not a fossil
fuel from before the flood because
now i had to use pitch and to build the
ark
and they should have been oil before the
flood
so can you comment for us on that well
it is known that oil can form quite
rapidly
if organic material is
in a certain condition and there have
been reports
of rapid oil formation and
that is something that occurred before
the flood already
as soon as sin came into the world
death came into the world so decay
became
part of the equation when
the world entered this new phase
animals were changed diets were changed
decay became a common factor
in the environment and so because the
pre-flood world was
so rich in in vegetation and organic
material
when decay takes place in those
situations then you would have pitch
formation
even before the flood of course when you
totally destroy the world
and bury all this vast amount of
organic material decayed and alive
then you will get oil formation
so in a sense oil is a fossil fuel
but it also formed to a
lesser extent but it did form before the
flood so
pitch would have been available
absolutely because there was also a lot
of time
since adam and the decay came in until
noah
absolutely there's a lot of questions
about the king of the north and south
since we've started three episodes ago
and we are going to be
dealing with it in an upcoming whatsapp
prof
yes we are going to do another
structured little
follow-up series like the last one
and i think a lot of the questions that
people have
will be addressed in that one because we
didn't actually do the bible studies
no we just mentioned it what is the king
of the north what is the king of the
south we mentioned a few verses in the
book of daniel
but we didn't go into the details the
details you find actually
in revelation chapter 11 yes and we
didn't go into that
so we will be dealing with the king of
the north and the king of the south
in the next episode or the next episodes
and we will talk about what their
attributes
are perhaps just briefly
the secular mindset where god is
separated from the equation
that's king of the south philosophy that
doesn't mean they don't have a religion
egypt was an idolatrous nation they had
many gods
but in a modern sense we have many gods
too we're also an
idolatrous nation your television can be
an idol
sports can be an idol anything that you
do
to excess is an idol so there are many
many idols which take you away from the
word of god
and the mindset of
the king of the south is not against
idolatry but against bringing
the specific truth into the equation
and the king of the north he is the king
of babylon
and the religion of babylon was baal
worship and it was mother and child
worship for that matter
and the king of the north just like the
king of the south was a god
king pharaoh was a god king and so the
king of the north is also
a god king but to him it is
essential that you bow down to his deity
you have to do that yes he forces you he
forces you to follow
his worship plan and if you
don't it's his way or the highway
and there's a difference between the two
mindsets but we'll deal with that in a
subsequent one
i see there's also a question who is
moab
the moabites came about because of the
unfortunate circumstances
surrounding the story of lot remember
his daughters conceived by him under
very unfortunate circumstances
and moab was one of the
descendants of that union
now the moabites were therefore
basically part of the family of
of abraham yes and ammonites the same
thing
so if you want to put that in a modern
setup you could say that in a modern
setup the moads
would be those that would be related
to those that had the truth but were
slightly off color in certain areas
or had different views in certain areas
which were not necessarily biblical
so that's where that comes in
there's also lots of questions on
alan white that endorsed the book
thoughts on daniel revelation by uriah
smith
and now they want to know if she
endorses the book didn't she know about
that he mentioning the turks being the
king of the north
there was a lot of debate about the king
of the north and the king of the south
amongst the pioneers and
uriah smith did a wonderful work in
writing
this book and showing what the the
thought pattern was and his position was
of course
that the king of the north represented
the turks
but others again on the basis of bible
study
said no this is this is inconsistent
with the bible and james white
was one of them and he said no the king
of the north must
be the papacy because
the king of the north is the one that
subjected
the children of israel to his
religion and he sent them to his
universities to educate them in that
religion and he changed their names
to represent his religion in other words
he wanted to incorporate them
into his religious system now
who does that in in the world today
obviously
that is the papacy so there were those
that thought that it was the papacy now
james white went on to the stage
and actually defended the position that
the king of the north
was the papacy and not the turks and he
did it
in a sharp fashion
using his evidence and he got rebuked
yes
that's the next question why did ellen
white review
he got rebuked not for what he said
he got reviewed for the way in which he
said
it he should have gone to his brother
and said listen what you are saying
is not biblically correct let's
think about it let's work on this
together let's see if we can
find the solution from the bible
and then if he didn't listen to that
then
the discussion would have been different
but he never did that he went straight
out and he attacked the man
instead of attacking the issue
and then that's why alan white then yes
there's no doubt
that james white was theologically
correct on the issue now
the book in general that was written
thoughts on daniel in revelation
had so many good features in it there
was this one point of controversy
but she endorsed the book yes
but that thought was brought out very
clearly
and rectified so there shouldn't be a
problem
to just make that correction in your
mind when you read the book
so i don't see a problem with it at all
okay and like you said
it will become clearer in the next
episode
absolutely we will be talking about it
in the next episode
okay there were also questions after
some of our previous episodes
about where the line should be drawn as
to
our involvement in politics right
and what about voting
some people felt that it was a civil
duty
to be involved in in these things so
where should we draw the line
perhaps we can take a statement from the
spirit of prophecy
to see if we can find some clarity over
there
so this is councils for the church page
the lord would have his people bury
political questions
on these themes silence is eloquence
christ
calls upon his followers to come into
unity on the pure
gospel principles which are plainly
revealed in the word of god
we cannot with safety vote for political
parties
for we do not know whom we are voting
for we cannot with safety take
part in any political scheme she does
say
in other places that you can become
involved in a local sphere
when it comes to those who have more
temperate views and views on temperance
as opposed to those who don't because
that's dealing with your local sphere
but when it comes to the political
scheme which side do you choose
which side do you choose in the debate
for example in the united states at the
moment
there are many issues on both sides that
you might agree with
and there are many issues on both sides
that you would not agree with
there are many issues on both sides
which
might sound biblical and there are many
issues on both sides which definitely
don't sound
biblical when you become a
citizen of the kingdom of god
then you become a representative
you become a representative of god's
kingdom to all
to all peoples nations tribes
and tongues now an ambassador
does he get to vote in your country no
let's say the french ambassador in south
africa does he get to vote and
when it comes to voting no why not
because he's not he's not a south
african he's representing
france for example if he's the french
ambassador or the german ambassador
or whoever now have you become a citizen
of god and you come
out and you are separate who do you
represent
god you represent god so those who are
christians
indeed will be branches of the true vine
and will bear the same fruit as the vine
your mind changes they will act in
harmony
in christian fellowship they will not
wear political badges but the badge
of christ now
can i be contentious sometimes we are
contentious right we spoke about black
lives matter that was quite a
contentious
issue and it's an issue that can make
one very hot under the collar
but let's say that in our country for
example
let's say you were a staunch supporter
of the previous regime
and then you became a christian
and certain issues of the previous
regime no longer gelled
with what you now believed
does that automatically make you a
follower of the subsequent
regime or let's put it pertinently if
one regime let's say
is an apartheid regime and the next
regime i'm not saying it is i'm just
saying
if it should be a marxist regime
would you then because you agree
disagree with aspects of one regime
switch over to the other regime
what if those are the only two options
how would you get involved
or would you preach the kingdom of god
it's just a question
they will act in harmony and christian
fellowship they will not wear political
badges but the badge of christ
what are we to do then let political
questions alone
there is a large vineyard to be
cultivated but while christians are to
work amongst
unbelievers they are not to appear like
worldlings
they are not to spend their time talking
politics or acting politics
for by so doing they give the enemy
opportunity
to come in and cause variance and
discord
now this doesn't mean that you cannot
discuss the impact
of a political system on
prophecy because the bible tells us we
must study
history we must study the workings of
god
amongst the nations we must understand
these things in a prophetic context
but as we have constantly stated in this
program
we are observers observers
god's children are to separate
themselves from politics from any
alliance with unbelievers do not take
part in political strife
separate from the world and refrain from
bringing into the church or school
ideas which will lead to contention and
disorder
dissension is the moral poison taken
into the system by human beings who are
selfish
and that is the position that
we should have now
one can certainly support
certain ideas but to
link it to a package is a very dangerous
thing to do
yes another question we had was
can you please explain what the
difference
between imputed and imparted
justification okay there's a slight
misunderstanding in this question
because
if we had said can you please explain
what's the difference between
an imputed and imparted righteousness
then it would be easier to deal with
because justification is
a judicial act
so what is imputed righteousness
and what is imparted righteousness
now we know that we have no
righteousness of our own
all our righteousness says the bible is
filthy rags
so the only claim we have to
righteousness
is the righteousness of christ now
imputed righteousness
is an alien righteousness which is
imputed to you reckoned
towards you as though it were yours
so martin luther called it an alien
righteousness it is a righteousness
outside of yourself
it is christ's righteousness which is
accredited to you
even though you are undeserving so it is
a gift from god
and it's a judicial act it is
saying this person
is reckoned righteous
because of my imputed
righteousness so it is a statement
and it is a judicial statement and it
comes
into effect the moment you accept
that you are a sinner that you
repent of your sins and that you lay
claim
to the promise of christ that he is your
redeemer
and he is your righteousness then that
judicial act comes into play
imparted righteousness
is the change that takes place within
you
as christ works in you so we can say
that imputed righteousness
is justification
imparted righteousness is sanctification
it is a process it's not something that
happens in
in a moment but it changes you
it can change you to the point where
your mother doesn't recognize you
anymore if you were a drunkard you are
no longer a drunkard if you were a thief
you are no longer a thief if you were a
liar
you are no longer a liar because that
voice and that power working in you
again
it is not used now becoming the bee's
knees
it is christ in you that is affecting
the change
so both imputed righteousness and
imparted righteousness or gifts from god
imputed righteousness is justification
imparted righteousness is sanctification
and that's that's how one should explain
it that's why you cannot say imputed and
imparted justification
because justification implies applies to
the imputed part but not to the imparted
ploy
thank you pleasure was lucifer and his
angels cast out before or
after the fall of man
while he was cast out before the fall of
man there was war in heaven
when adam and eve were deceived by the
serpent
he was already down here on earth he
still had access to heaven
how do we know that we do because in the
book of job
it tells us that there was a council in
heaven
and the representatives of the created
worlds
came and presented themselves before god
and the lord asked satan where are you
from
and he says i come from walking
to and fro upon the earth now that
statement
implies ownership if you
walk to and fro that means
you have ownership today there are
little signs everywhere
which say trespassers will be prosecuted
now does the owner of the land concern
himself with a little sign
no no he doesn't care too it's about the
sign because he's the owner
so christ was the original
creator and owner of everything yes
and then he gave dominion to adam and
eve
and satan stole the dominion
from them and he became the
representative
yes now how long did that
continue until the cross
because there christ paid the price
and satan was vanquished
and he lost his position i saw satan
fall like
lightning from heaven his access to
heaven yes
but he and his angel had been thrown out
after the rebellion
and the solution that god had to the
rebellion
was the creation of man yeah
thank you so let's see what else we have
got
the sign of jonah
yes now i think what the people are
talking about
here is the issue of three days
and three nights for as jonah was three
days and three nights in the whale's
belly
so shall the son of man be three days
and three nights in the heart of the
earth
and so there are many that say there
wasn't a friday crucifixion
it was a wednesday crucifixion
and there were church denominations that
preach
that but the general christian world has
always
accepted the friday to sunday issue now
how do we get the answer to this one
we have to understand the historic
context we have to understand
the the mode of reckoning time
in the jewish economy
they used inclusive reckoning any
portion of a day
was considered a day
so whether it was an hour or whether it
was the full 24 hours
it was a day now originally in the bible
it defined the day as and it
was evening and it was morning the first
day
and it was evening and it was morning
the second day and later on it tells us
in the bible from evening to evening
shall your sabbaths be so a day starts
when the sun sets and the day
ends at the next sunset it's
actually a beautiful system
so when would it be day one any portion
of the first
day night period and so we talk about
days or we talk about evenings and
mornings
as a designation of the day if you look
go to daniel
the 2300 day prophecy it's evening and
morning right
and it was evening and it was morning
the first day that designates a day
so it wouldn't be wrong to translate it
days in that case for example
okay so that was the way in which they
worked
they used inclusive reckoning they took
it further any portion of a year was
considered the first year so you
wouldn't say okay now it is september
and your year will end in september
so if you came in in december and you
were still part of the system that was
year one that's why you get the anomaly
that nebuchadnezzar was in
his second year and daniel already in
his third year although
nebuchadnezzar was the one who'd
actually
taken daniel to babylon right it's
that reckoning the recognition that one
is
right and the babylonians had what they
called an ascension
which was not reckoned so
the bible is absolutely spot on
it is humanity that gets
mixed up and muddled up when it comes to
these issues so
when was christ crucified we have to
find the answer in the bible
yes and i always like to and by the way
i
i did a whole bible study on that and i
think it's on the maybelline discovery's
web page
yes i'll put a link to it i think it's
in bible answers
yeah so if we go to the gospel i'd like
to take the gospel of mark
because it shows it very nicely
and very clearly and we can start there
with
chapter 11.
now i
i like this story because the gospel of
mark
from chapter 11 describes the last week
in jesus life from the triumphant entry
now jesus had spent the sabbath
with lazarus and his family
remember he had resurrected lazarus and
he had spent the sabbath there
and on the first day of the week they
entered into jerusalem and lazarus was
the one
leading the ass the foal of a donkey
right
and this was an amazing scene
and then it describes to us the
various situations that happened and
what happened
and the stories and what jesus taught
and everything is in there
but it is sequential now it doesn't
mention
which day it was but you by working back
and find out exactly that it was the
first day of the week it was
sunday when the triumphant entry took
place
so jesus had spent the sabbath
with lazarus and his family and it's a
it's a beautiful story because
he actually went to have
lunch sabbath lunch with
uh simon and simon
was a leper and jesus had healed him
from his leprosy and he should have been
very grateful right and mary magdalene
was also there
and she brought this beautiful ointment
this
wonderfully expensive perfume
and she anointed jesus's head
for his burial as he claimed
and she washed his feet with her tears
and
simon was giving him
the look and saying
ah i know i know he was thinking this
man healed me from my leprosy
but does he know what manner of woman
this is because
obviously he knew right
and then jesus told him that
if you were forgiven much you loved much
and he told the little parable about the
one who'd been forgiven much and the one
who'd not been forgiven much
and that all took place on the sabbath
day now comes the triumphant entry
he's already been anointed for his death
now i find it very interesting that
this week that is described here
to me is the antithesis
to the creation week okay
so the creation week was six days
one day rest yes right and here you have
six days of labor and a rest in the
grave
yes now if we look at it in that way
let's see if we can
find something interesting
and when they came nigh unto jerusalem
unto
bethage and bethany at the mount of
olives he senteth forth two of his
disciples and says unto them go your way
into the village
over and against you and as soon as
you be entered into it
you shall find a cult tie the one tied
where on never man set loose him
and bring him and if any man say unto
you
why do you do this say that the lord has
need of him
and straightway he will send him heather
and then it tells the story of the
triumphant intro that's day one
yes it doesn't mention the day doesn't
say anything about it it just tells us
that's
the day one and if you drop down to
verse 12. now my bible
is the normal king james bible and
i've mentioned this before but if i can
show you over here
you see verse 12 is written in bold face
now i like a bible that has new
paragraphs indicated by
bold face like this one because then the
thoughts don't run
into each other for example verse 11 is
not bold face
neither any of those so that's all one
paragraph and here the next paragraph
starts and it says
and on the morrow when they were come
from bethany
he was hungry and that was the new day
so that was day two and you carry on
verse 13
and 14 or not boldface then verse 15 is
a new paragraph it's written in boldface
and it goes down and you come to verse
20. it's boldfest and it says
in the morning as they passed by new
paragraphs so this is a
new thought this is a new day this is
day three
so it's useful to have that because it
tells you
close of one little story beginning of
next little story
and verse 12 says and on the morning
so that's the next day the second day
yeah so you don't know what day it is
doesn't say that
now we know it was sunday because the
sabbath he had been
uh with lazarus but now he was the
triumphant enteral and lazarus was
leading
the fall and on the morrow when they had
come
from bethany he was hungry and seeing a
fig tree
far off so here is this this very
mournful story
of the fig tree now i don't want to give
a whole bible study
on its own it's almost irresistible
are amazing because figs actually start
making their fruits before the leaves
come
so if there are lots of leaves you would
expect what lots of fruits all right
that was not the season for friggs so
here was a fig tree it was full of
leaves so it should have had figs and
the others
had no leaves so you wouldn't expect
figs on them yet okay so he gets there
and he curses the fig tree because it
had
no fruit it was a presumptuous fig tree
now what is interesting to me in that
parable
one of my family members was very
enraged by this parable because it
seemed so unreasonable that jesus should
have done this
but i don't think she understood the
meaning of this parable
in this in the story it's not a parable
it's an
an acted parable if you like the fig
tree represented of course israel
and it had leaves so it was
presumptuously
pretentious but it had no fruit
the others were not presumptuous they
had no no leaves so you couldn't expect
fruit right
and they of course represented the
gentile nations
that didn't have fruit and they didn't
have leaves they weren't pretending to
know the truth and be
representatives whatsoever and he cursed
the fig tree
because israel was of course the one
that rejected the truth so that was day
two
and then it this is the last week of
jesus's life
so if he was crucified on the wednesday
then we should find it in here right
correct okay then we drop
down to verse 20
and there it says and in the morning
so that is the third day now and then it
tells you
everything that happened and what jesus
taught
and a long story
about everything that jesus taught on
that specific day
and it goes through quite a number of
chapters
in the bible and then
so if that was the third day and let's
let's for the sake of argument
assume that we are dealing with from
sunday
so then we had sunday
monday tuesday gone
and then chapter 14 it tells us
after two days was the feast of the
passover
and of unleavened breed and the chief
priests and the scribes sought
how they might take him by craft
so let's read that again in two days so
we are now here on the fourth day now
and it tells us what's happening on the
fourth day
and that judas went out to
betray the lord with the pharisees he
made a deal with them
he actually wanted jesus to
show his power yes he wanted to force
his hand
as it were and then if we drop down to
verse 12 you will again
see that it is dalton
and it says and the first day of
unleavened bread
so because it was the second one now
it's the
fourth day so this is the fifth day
and what happened then they killed the
passover so what day was that
that was the thursday yes his disciples
said to him
where wilt thou that we go and prepare
that they're my
ears eaters the passover now
they ate the passover at sunset right
yes
so once the sunset was over what day
were you in then
the sixth day then you were in the sixth
day so on the fifth day
they're preparing for the lord's supper
and everything that happened on the
lord's supper
and that was the fifth day now when the
sun had set
then it was it seeks the sixth day
this is the thursday afternoon in the
evening
is the beginning of the sixth day
correct so
on that night thursday evening when it
became
friday that evening was friday the sixth
day
jesus went out to the garden of
gethsemane
and everything that happened there in
the garden
i'll be doing a sermon next on
what the issue is and how it relates to
our time what is important
that'll be the next sermon that we'll be
doing
on amazing discoveries and so
that friday the night
after the thursday had closed after
sunset
jesus was arrested and jesus
was tried through the night and they had
the night trial
but they weren't allowed to
pass judgment if it was not day it was
one of their rules
so i just want to make it clear that if
i understand it now so we're talking
about the sixth day
this is the thursday evening in our
reckoning
until the friday so during the night
they were
busy with the trials of jesus and
straightway in the morning that's
chapter 15. so this is now
friday morning yes the chief priests
held a consultation with the elders
and the scribes and the whole council
and bound jesus and carried him away
so here was the morning trial because
now it was legal
it was very early in the morning the sun
had just
risen and off they went
to pilot and then it tells you
everything
that happened on that particular day
and then on that friday
they crucified him on that same day
but now it's interesting that the bible
actually gives us the hours
gives us the hours of this particular
day
and they told you what happened to him
and how they took him to herod
and how he was taken to the place of the
skull
and then it says in verse 24 and when
they had crucified him they parted his
garments costing lots upon them
what every man should take and it was
the third
hour and they crucified him
now when was the third hour
now when they started reckoning
not when does the day start and when
does the day end
but they started
counting hours at six o'clock in the
morning
so from six o'clock the third hour would
be nine o'clock
so by nine o'clock on that morning
they had already procured all of these
issues
and he was on the cross
and the superscription of his accusation
was written
over the king of the jews
and then we dropped down to verse 33 and
when the sixth hour
was come there was darkness
over the whole land until the ninth hour
so it gives us the hours so there was
darkness from the sixth hour which was
twelve o'clock noon until the ninth hour
which was three o'clock in the afternoon
so we're all still on this one day
and at the ninth hour that's three
o'clock in the afternoon
jesus cried with a loud voice saying
which is being interpreted my god my god
why has thou
forsaken me and this is when he died
so we know that it was before
the sabbath now let's just make sure
in verse 42 it spells it out
now when the evening was come so was
going into the late afternoon evening
stage
right it was still the friday he died at
three o'clock
it says because it was the preparation
that is the day before
the sabbath you can't go wrong then now
this word the preparation
was used specifically for the
preparation for the seventh day sabbath
correct because there's some people that
say
that was the preparation for the yearly
sabbath for the ceremonial sabbath
but this makes it quite clear that it
was
a high sabbath it was a yearly sabbath
which happened to coincide
with a weekly sabbath which made it a
high sabbath and if you consider this
the last week of jesus's life
it is actually the week of recreation
to recreate humanity into the image of
god through what we just discussed the
imputed and imparted
righteousness of christ so this last
week which started off with a triumphant
entry the first time when he allowed
himself
to be acknowledged as the messiah yes
amazing right and they really
acknowledged also like the messiah and
the king
and the king yes he was messiah he was
king
he was the one and they shouted he is
the one
that comes riding on the donkey they
knew the prophecy means
and here he comes and this is the crew
recreation week it is as
important a week as the creation
in fact it's more important because it
reveals the entire character of god
so beautiful it was the preparation that
is the day
before the sabbath and then
they laid him in the grave right and
they anointed him as far as they could
but then they had to stop
yes because why the sabbath was coming
so it says in verse 16
in chapter 16 verse 1 and when
the sabbath was passed so we know that
the sabbath is when he was
in the grave because it says previously
in verse 46
and he brought fine linen and took him
down and wrapped him in the linen and
laid him in a sepulchre which was
you out of a rock and rolled the stone
unto the door of the sepulcher and mary
magdalene
and mary the mother of joseph beheld
where he was laid
so there he laid for the sabbath day
that's the seventh day
and when the sabbath was over
mary magdalene and mary the mother of
james
and salome had brought sweet spices
that they might come and anoint him
and very early in the morning the first
day of the week explicit
okay so let's work it back the first day
of the week we know
it's a sunday the sabbath he was in the
grave
the friday we have the hours so that we
know what took place
from sunset thursday to
sunset friday so three o'clock he had
died
enough time for him to go into the grave
in fact pilate was surprised that he had
died yes
because they had to break the legs of
the others
to hasten the process yes because
they had to get him off before the
sabbath correct according to
their rules right so this whole issue is
very clear
from the triumphant entry you had day
one day two
day three day four day five day six
giving you the hours then it had the
sabbath
laying in the grave rest so it follows
the creation week yes six days shalt
thou
labor but the sabbath is rest he
rested in the grave and he rose
to continue his work as high priest
on the first day of the week the creator
correct in the first week of creation
the creator
the same creator that made the first
week rested in the grave
the second week how far
according to their custom not according
to the bible
were they allowed to walk on a sabbath
day
weren't allowed to work more than a
kilometer right so they had all kinds of
interesting plans
as to how to walk further so they used
to hide food
under a stone and said well there were
you eat that's your home so now you can
walk the next one so
didn't you also mention some time that
they had in their coats
woven in and then they take it off and
put it down and then
they can walk another correct now
that sunday morning there were two
gentlemen
that walked all the way to emmaus
remember that
correct and what did jesus do he
appeared to them
and he walked with them bible study he
gave them a bible study
so it was a working day for him and he
walked many kilometers on that day
so the bible is very clear
there was no wednesday crucifixion
because then this whole gospel would be
null and void it's beautiful how this
whole
creation week and crucifixion week
come into harmony and also with the
whole plan of salvation absolutely
so you have the six days and the day of
rest and the six days
and the day of rest will there be future
prophets
with prophetic light
well joel said in chapter 2 verse 28 and
shall come to pass
afterwards that i will pour out my
spirit upon
all flesh and your sons and your
daughters shall prophesy
your old men shall dream dreams and your
young men
shall see visions so this is a prophecy
that under the latter reign there would
be
manifestations now prophecy has
two meanings one could be visions and
the other one could be
preaching the truth both are used
interchangeably
now how many prophets were normally
called at the time
not many right so
we believe that the prophetic gift was
given to ellen g white but that doesn't
mean that others didn't also receive it
we had william foy for example who had
visions and heisenfass had
visions but they refused to speak on
these issues
and it doesn't mean that this prophetic
gift
is a one-time issue
people will have dreams and people will
have
meaningful dreams but that should be not
be the
norm whereupon to base
your religion a manifestation
is not the best proof
for a reality the best proof
always lies in the word of god
so yes i believe that people will have
dreams
yes i believe that dreams can be very
meaningful
and yes i believe that in the end time
god will lead many to righteousness
through dreams but that doesn't
make them prophets it's something for
them
personally just for interest sake
we were speaking about emmaus
now when jesus appeared to them he could
have
come there in shining glory and they
would have fallen on their
faces and they would have rejoiced and
they would have worshipped him and they
would have
known that this is the jesus christ whom
they had served
and he has been resurrected hallelujah
praise the lord did he do it that way
no he concealed
his glory he concealed his
divinity then recognized him not
they saw him as a fellow traveler
who had a better insight of the
prophecies than they had yes
so then jesus goes and he expounds to
them from what
from the scriptures aha
everything concerning himself he gives
them a bible study
interesting also it's the old testament
well there was no new testament so he
gave them a bible study
and what did they say our hearts
burned inside of us isn't that correct
and then at the meal yeah i just want to
add
they ran back all the rest of the way
that's correct when they recognized it
but when did they recognize it
they ran back after he had
blessed the bread and they recognized
him and
then for the first time they probably
saw the marks in his hands
and their eyes were opened and they
recognized who he was
and they must have stormed him and he
was gone
why did he do that because they
were the ones who were witnesses
and they shouldn't have come and said we
saw this great manifestation we saw
jesus and he spoke to us and he's alive
he's alive
no they were to give bible studies
so this is how it will work in the end
as well
yes people will have dreams
personally i don't
think that we will have a
new prophet in the sense
of daniel or
jeremiah at the end of time
i believe many people will
be led to discover the truth by even
miraculous means but
the word will be the basis and through
the writings of elegy white which is
basically
a telescope which magnifies
this word the word is the basis
and the writings of ellen g white are
merely a telescope
they are not the word they are the
telescope to magnify the word
everything has been told that we need
for the time that we are living in and
the time that we
are approaching and therefore
i personally don't believe that there
will be
another prophet like that but if there
should
be one yes then that profit should be
tested
according to the biblical criteria
correct
now i gave a lecture once on
god's guiding gift yes perhaps you can
put that link on
because all the criteria are in there
and we can see
whether uh you know they actually apply
and if they apply then those same
criteria
it's not enough that someone gets up and
makes some biblical noises and then all
of a sudden
you think that that person is a prophet
because you have to be careful they
could be
false prophets there were even those
people like that in ellen white's day
exactly
she that even went to live with her
there's a whole story that they can read
and that but
if you qualify the prophet or the person
saying that he's got a message from god
and all this and he's a prophet
according to the bible that's your
standard absolutely
and then we we get this question a lot
yes is the earth round or is it flat
now i don't think we're going to answer
that question
we can we can answer it with a statement
right yes so let's look at the statement
this is a letter that was written in
it's from the spirit of prophecy and she
was writing to a brother
who was for the flat earth
and he had some
ideas and he was very strong
in terms of these ideas and he felt that
this should be made a central part of
the teaching yes
and so she said my brother our work is
to teach the third angel's message
any kind of theory or hobby that satan
can lead the minds of men to dwell upon
he will draw their attention to so that
they shall
not be engaged in giving the solemn
message for this
time do not my brother
become entangled with the ideas that
have no connection with the work for
this time it is better to be teaching
the truth as it is in jesus better to be
seeking for true godliness heart
holiness freedom from all selfishness
freedom from all envies and jealousies
it is better to pray and humble the soul
before god
and let the world round or flat be
just as god has made it
try most earnestly by faithful
continuance and well-doing
to seek for a clear clear title in the
inheritance
in the earth made new better lead the
flock of god to drink
at the higher streams better by precept
and example
seek god while he may be found call upon
him while he is near there is
a revival needed in the church
when the teachers are drinking fresh
draughts from the well of bethlehem
then they can lead the people to the
living stream my soul is
weighed down with the burden of
condition of things in new york
may the lord raise up helpers men whom
we can teach humble men we can lead
to bear a clear sharp testimony in faith
god help you to seek his face to walk
carefully to put
self out of sight and to exalt jesus
this
is the great need of the present time
whether the world is round
or flat will not save a soul
but whether men believe and obey means
everything here is another statement
from the spirit of prophecy comes from
manuscript 145 from 1904
i'm not going to read the whole
statement i'm going to read
just the bold portion here we have not
to do with the question whether this
world is round or flat
the important thing is to serve god with
full purpose of a renewed heart
sanctified and made holy by the
cleansing blood
of jesus christ but just for interest
sake here is another one
from manuscript releases volume 21 and
it says
let those who are presenting theories
as to whether the earth is round or flat
leave this question
for god has not given it to them to
solve and earnestly
inquire what shall i do that i may have
eternal life let them heed the answer
thou shalt love the lord thy god with
all thy heart and with all thy soul and
with all thy strength
and with all thy mind and thy neighbor
as thyself
i think we can leave it
is it wrong to study these things is it
wrong to study any aspect of science i
don't think so
but if we make it prominent that we have
a specific
view in this area you will have
confrontation with those who have
another view
in this area and the gospel will be lost
in in the commotion
so we at amazing discoveries are not
going to get
involved in that debate
which doesn't mean that we don't study
it but we won't get involved
in the debate correct
and this is a question that comes up so
much
what are we to do yes lots of
yeah must we leave the city yes that's
the question i was just about to
mention now we're not going to talk
about leaving the cities in this
particular chat that we are having
we will leave that for the next one yes
that's also coming in the next
episodes the next episodes will again be
dealing with the times we are living in
and whether we should leave the cities
and where we
are in this in the scheme of things
and what will happen what will happen
in particular nations i mean these are
very very interesting questions
but people ask how do we grow our own
vegetables what do we do if we don't
have
piece of land what do we do under this
circumstance what do we do under that
circumstance
and there again there is no hard and
fast rule
god has to do the leading
we shouldn't act out of impulse but we
should
act as god opens the way and as he shows
us clearly
what our duty is in regard to these
things
and how we should move she has a
statement where she says secure for
yourselves
land where you can grow your own
vegetables
because the time of buying and selling
will become
very acute and people say well they
don't have any experience in
growing their own vegetables now
you know you can on a very small scale
do microculture
and you can grow
your own provisions
in a house in a house in an apartment
you don't have to have a vast track of
land in order to do this
so you can have
sprouting for example is a way to get
good fresh greens so
stock up on some good seeds ones that
that sprout very easily and that are
very useful in terms of sprouting
would of course be alfalfa
that is one that sprouts very well so
stock up on some of those seeds get some
sprouting bottles and
uh start sprouting look it up on the
internet that's right
there's a lot of there's lots of videos
there's so much information out there i
mean if you take me and my wife we
we weren't used to this but if you take
some time
start studying it then it's actually fun
and it's easy to do very easy to do and
micro greens
i mean micro greens are amazing so what
would you
what would you sprout red seeds that
sprout
start with stuff that really works every
time alfalfa works
another sprout that works would be
chickpeas
or lentils or mung beans they sprout
easily
don't work with stuff that gives you
great headaches
soy beans are very difficult to sprout
and they will
they will discourage you so start with
the stuff that works the simple stuff
and the same for microgreens microgreens
are absolutely fantastic
but they they can be done in an
apartment you don't need space for that
so micro greens ones that that really
work
well are
sunflower seeds they can even use the
cheap
sunflower seeds that still come in their
shells
and you can grow the micro greens to
this size and you can harvest them
cut them off with a pair of scissors and
you can make
put them in your stir fries add them to
your vegetables
you can eat them green while they are
still small
until they become too large then they're
chewy well then you start the next batch
right
you can have great sandwich you can put
them in your sandwich
and so you can get excellent food
another one that
is very good for micro micro growing
is flax seed
amazing you wouldn't expect it but it
makes a beautiful seed
there is of course wheatgrass that you
can use but wheatgrass
is something that you would have to
juice whereas
sunflower seeds and
another one that's very good for
microgreens would be broccoli seed
for sprouting makes a wonderful
wonderful micro green so you don't need
anything else but that just to augment
your
your minerals and everything that you
need if you have a little
piece of land then you are a king and a
queen
so should we be growing our own
vegetables well i did give a lecture on
it some time ago we can go through some
of the
basic issues if you want to do
farming that that supplies
all the mineral needs that you require
then organic farming is the way to go
there are many things that you can do
but organic farming is
it's just it's just so much so much
better yeah now some of the minerals
that you need for plant growth
would be nitrogen phosphorus potassium
magnesium
sulfur and calcium the nitrogen of
course is for protein
phosphorus for energy transfer the
potassium for carbohydrate
metabolism and water relations and
the magnesium you find in the
chlorophyll molecule
sulfur you need to incorporate in
proteins and in
in many coenzymes that work together
with enzymes calcium
for the cell walls etc etc
now modern agriculture
tends to concentrate on these very
minerals
and to supply them in a soluble form
so basically they're feeding the plant
yeah
now in organic culture you never feed
the plant
you feed the soil and there's this is
the fundamental difference between the
two
and those who are very steeped
in feeding the plant
culture they cannot get their mind
off and around this concept of feeding
the soil
now if you feed a plant with these basic
minerals you can get
quite a substantial plant but what about
all the other minerals that you are
missing
because they're very important now some
of the minerals are
mobile and some are immobile the mobile
ones would be nitrogen
phosphorus potassium and magnesium and
the immobile ones would be calcium
sulfur
and the borons and the iron and copper
and manganese
and zinc
now do we have to know all of these
details
and that all makes do you have to be a
biochemist in order to understand this
this is what discourages a lot of people
in beginning
into getting into it so let's make this
very simple
by the way if you wanted to really start
debating the issue magnesium
is absolutely essential for plants
because chlorophyll contains magnesium
right
and so people think that they must add a
lot of magnesium to the ground but if
you do that
if the magnesium concentration in the
ground gets too high the bacteria die
so then you are basically feeding the
plant here magnesium
is readily absorbed by the blood through
the leaves
through the stomata so with the morning
dew
there are minerals also in the morning
due and it takes it up that way
so there are many things that can become
extremely complicated let's try and make
it simple
with some basic facts
minerals need interaction with other
minerals
so if you look at interactions between
minerals you'll see a lot of minerals
mentioned here
selenium iron calcium you can see all
these cross reactions how they interact
with each other
so taking just five basic minerals and
feeding it to the plant which is what
the modern fertilizer industry does
you can get a good looking plant but you
have
so many diseases and you have so much
spraying to do to keep them going
that it becomes unbelievable and you
actually want the plant to be able to
access all of these minerals now where
do you find these minerals you find them
in the soil
just like minerals and vitamins also
need to interact with each other so you
need
a lot of minerals zinc is a very
important one selenium is important
iron is important copper is important
you need
you need them all of them
and just as you have many vitamin
interactions it's not just oh i need
this vitamin no this vitamin interacts
with that one that one interacts with
that one
you must have a whole food scenario in
your mind
you must have a complete process
now modern agriculture tends to add
soluble nutrients to the ground to feed
the plant as we have said
and organic culture works like this yes
this is the most productive
uh agriculture in the world man has not
touched it this is a tropical jungle
so this is what you would find in the
amazon for example
and who's the gardener god god is the
gardener
no plow has touched this the most
productive land
in the world how does god do his
gardening
there's a lot of debris and dirt on this
ground right this is a forest floor
and what have you got growing there
you've got fungi you've got
trees that are decaying well this one
looks like it was logged so let's just
say it wasn't logged it fell
over by itself right and you have leaf
debris and you have all of these things
and no plow
and you have these massive trees
and they are producing so that millions
of animals can survive now how does god
do that well all of that organic
material
feeds the organisms in the soil
and you have microorganisms and you have
macro organisms
and they eat this organic material just
like you eat mechanic
organic material and in the process
they actually supply the nutrients for
the plants that are growing
now how does that happen so you have
basically a soil web
where you have all of these creatures
like nematodes and arthropods and
protozoans and bacteria
all mixed in and then you have some of
the irritating ones like your molds
that dig up your garden and birds that
add
nitrogen to the soil and all of this
is one harmonious interaction
in one of those forests right all takes
place
now the soil itself must contain
all the minerals all the minerals in the
periodic table
not just five so now
if you're coming to an area where the
soil
is depleted it's not a very good soil
how do you fix it you don't despair
you fix it fix it all right so you can
there are certain things that you can
mix into your soil
uh soft rock phosphate
is a wonderful material
soft rock phosphate is a rock that
you've
changed into a powdery form and it's
rich in
many minerals but high in phosphorus
but it's not in the soluble form it's
locked into this rock so
when you make this rock fine the plant
cannot access it
it has to be somehow leeched out of that
rock
but it contains the phosphorus now god
doesn't sprinkle fertilizer over his
forests
but he has rocks in his soil that
contain
phosphorus so if you come into an area
and there's not enough of it well then
get hold of some soft rock phosphate if
you can
in some areas it's readily available in
other areas
it's not so available don't despair
there are other plans limestone
calcitic lime is very rich in calcium
but it contains a lot of other minerals
as well
a dolomatic lime contains magnesium
so if your if your soil is incredibly
magnesium poor
you might want to use dolomatic lime but
generally speaking
calcitic lime is the way to go for
organic farming
calcitic lime will add all the calcium
that you need and it's very cheap and
you can get it at
any co-op and you just get a bag
and you add it to your soil
now if your soil is very
alkaline and you want to make it more
acid you can
add gypsum which contains sulfur
sulfate and that makes it more acid so
in a very alkaline soil you would add
gypsum
in a very acidic soil you would help
add calcitic lime you can add
volcanic dust volcanic dust is amazing
it has all the minerals so if you cannot
get all the rocks phosphate
then you can add volcanic dust granite
dust on the other hand
is very rich in potassium but it has all
the other minerals as well
right so if you can add whatever
combination
of these that you can find in your area
to your soil
it won't change anything it won't just
increase it'll just
make the minerals put the minerals in
the soil but won't make them available
to the plant
so that's why conventional people will
say to you
that's useless because you're just
putting it in the soil you're putting in
the soil and the plant can't get all of
it
okay now this is where the beauty of
organic farming comes in
we'll discuss that in a moment so rock
fertilizers are added at double the
commercial quantities
so you can add a lot to the soil and the
beauty is
that then you're done yeah for the next
few years
you've added it to the soil now you've
got to make a plan
to get the minerals out of that into the
plants
so add green manure with your mineral
fertilizer
and rock powders to make them more
effective
bacteria in the soil here's the trick
produce acids that make the minerals in
the soil available to the plants
so you want to have bacteria in your
soil how do you get bacteria into your
soil
you have to feed the soil now what feeds
the soil
the debris the compost
the organic material they have to eat
something
just like you have to eat something so
they have to eat organic materials so
you supply the organic material either
as greenman europe the best is compost
parts of it and then all the other
organisms
the earthworms will come into your soil
and they will take it down and the
bacteria will have a munching feast
now your stomach produces an
acid to digest food right protein
so the bacteria produces acid to digest
the organic material now that acid has a
two-way function it helps digest the
organic material that you've added to
the soil
but it also leaches the minerals out of
the rock out of the soil and the plant
gets it now how does the plant get it in
a surge
or continuous continuous
that's what you want and that is the
beauty
of organic gardening so
the most important thing in organic
garden
is compost compost is the heart of your
it is the food of your garden so now
when you have cardboard and you have
paper
and you have food waste
in your house and you have
leaf leaves and all of these issues
they become gold yes you don't throw
them away
so you can use paper you can use yard
waste you can use
food waste and all of this goes
into making compost
you can of course just go and buy
compost but if
you can't buy or sell you have to make
your own right
now a very good way to make compost is
to have
a little container like this where you
throw these
plant materials in and
you allow them to form compost
to decay now compost should be
moist but it shouldn't be wet so you
must constantly keep it
moist but not soggy it mustn't stink
it must have this glorious earthy
smell so that even the bacteria
would say oh this is a grand restaurant
i love this stuff
so compost is the heart and soul of
organic farming
composting works best in wooden bins
wire bins
straw bales etc you can set up any
system if you have a big
plot then i'll show you what you can do
in a moment
so you loosen the ground where you will
place your compost pile
make your compost pile two meters high
with a concave top
and alternate layers of soil straw
and weeds basically you want brown
material green material brown material
green material
now that's when you do it professionally
if you don't do it professionally
because you don't have time
like me just chuck everything on a pile
give water pray and hope for the best
and it works yes you have to dig and
it's a little bit work more work you
take
the indicate stuff off take the decayed
stuff
out the bottom turn it around so when i
need it i dig it out at the bottom
and then you carry on like here's so
here are little mechanisms you can do
and you can become very fancy
you can make little containers with hay
bales
and leave little gaps for air to come
through and then you throw all this
material in there then the bale actually
becomes part of the compost
so when it rots away it becomes part of
the next one anything that can decay
goes in there so start with a couple of
layers if you want to do it
professionally
if you don't have time i used to do it
this way
just put the hay bales around put the
compost in the middle
and then by the end of the season half
of it has become compost
turn the bale around take the outside
off add it to the compost do it for
another season
it actually is quite fun then you can
use raised beds the older you become
the better the raised bed is because you
don't have to bend down the whole time
too
yes gravity is the enemy of anybody
who gets on in yours so a raised bed is
very nice you can use
anything to make a raised bed here
they've used concrete blocks
you can stack two or three on top of
each other you can just place
regular plant debris even branches
in the bottom and just have the top
little layer
filled with soil and then a rich layer
of
compost and if your soil has these
added things like rock phosphate or
calcitic lime in it
then you have all the minerals and
these bacteria are so happy with the
compost
that they start making the most
marvelous
marvelous products another thing that
you want to consider is using heirloom
seed heirloom seed is seed that has not
been manipulated
and you get many stores that provide
heirloom seed you can just look it up in
the internet you can
uh order them
and people are becoming a little bit
wiser i see even our
stores have hellum seeds now i nearly
fell on my back the other day
the nice thing about helium seeds is
their flavor they might not bear as many
as the others
but their quality is just amazing a beef
steak tomato for example is a
marvelous thing so you can grow
any of these wonderful products in
in the open air or in a little
greenhouse
if you if you're living in a cold area
and organic tomatoes tomatoes as
some would say are just amazing
this is my boss and she is
here with our parrot this is a number of
years ago
and these were some of the tomatoes from
our little garden and
we had a net around it
and a shade cloth net and then we grew
the tomatoes
in this fashion now just a little tip if
you grow a tomato
it grows up right and it makes many side
branches
if you nip carefully read up about it
and about the side branches and only
keep the main
one going up then you will get tomatoes
at the bottom
and then the next crop and the next crop
and the next crop
try to clear the bottom leaves so that
the bottom
doesn't get wet feet then it doesn't get
mold so easily it doesn't rot
so easily and it makes a beautiful plant
another thing to remember with a tomato
plant
is that you want a very good root stock
now when you make a seedling and it
grows up and the roots are like this
and you plant it again as as far as the
roots are
you will get a nice plant but it won't
be a very strong plant
what you do is when you have the plant
about this high
yes let's say about 10 centimeters high
you pluck off the bottom little tiny
leaves
and then you plant it deeper than the
root system
it'll make roots all along that area and
give you a much stronger plant
and don't be afraid to take off the
bottom blondes and then
those fine little hairs
they make roots yes they make roots so
we keep the bottom clean like this and
then we grow them up
and then you start harvesting the bottom
right and eventually it'll go through
the roof if it can
so another little thing that you can do
is you can
tie it up up there and then you can
loosen it
and lay it on the ground and let it go
up again
and then you can get so many one plant
from one plant you can feed so many
people it's an amazing thing to do
it's fun but as i said in the beginning
you can do microculture in your house
then you have good greens to eat and
augment
what you have together with simple foods
like potatoes etc
and this is what our tomato crop looked
like
and that's a nice beef steak tomato
one slice of that on a on a piece of
bread with
avocado and you are living better than a
king
yeah these were some of our cucumbers
you could kill someone with them if you
hit them over the head with it
so it's really fun to do and the rewards
are amazing i must agree
that the taste you cannot compare it
with
anything because no when the first time
i tasted
the your own grown uh organic organic
if you take if you take a lettuce out of
an organic garden
and you take a lettuce out of a store
the one tastes like water with a crisp
crispiness to it and the other one
you have to actually almost get used to
the taste yeah because it's got all the
minerals in it
wow what's this uh some people will say
there's something wrong with it yeah
but once you've gotten used to it you
can't go back to the other right
it's like the your bread recipe yes um
when before we made the bread like
our own bread used to buy strawberries
now for three years now we've been only
baking our own bread if i get a
strawberry now
it's uneditable almost
yeah it's fun now you know some people
ask
well how do you deal with all the pests
because
you know non-organic farming because the
plants have no resilience because
they're feeding the plants
with the minimum number of minerals that
they need
they look fine but they don't have what
it takes
even their immune system is very weak
so organic farming is more
the plant is more resilient now how do
you
deal with pests for example we make use
of very
simple pesticides
you will get pests generally speaking
the weaker plants are more susceptible
than stronger plants
so if you have for example a broccoli
patch
and one of them is full of plant lice
then rather than stressing yourself into
a coma
take that one out and don't put it into
your compost
don't use it again
throw it away get rid of it get rid of
it
and the other should be relatively
uninfected but if you do
get white lice or white fly or
any one of these things which can happen
particularly if it's warm and
moist and you'll get fungus and
tomatoes very susceptible you can keep
the bottom
free of leaves that helps but you can
make
very very simple pesticides
which also are natural fungicides
and one of the best ones to use is neem
oil
now there's a little there's a little
recipe that you can use
to make a spray with neem oil
and basically it's two parts neem oil
and one part natural
liquid soap now you cannot use
commercial liquid soap like dishwashing
liquid which is a liquid soap
but it has so many other stuff in it
that
that is not good so
you need natural liquid soap so if you
can buy
from a health food store natural liquid
soap that
is natural soap with no garbage in it
fine then use that then you use
two parts neem oil one part liquid soap
if you cannot buy the liquid soap make
your own
get a bar of natural soap
homemade soap not chemically
soap with all of these artificial
sulfates and stuff that make it foam
natural so we've got to well your wife
that's all the
um lecture on making soap so i'll put
the link of that also
i'll put a link on that but if you don't
buy make your own sub that's fine don't
buy a bar of soap
use a very simple soap you can use
simple soaps that they use for washing
for example
and then you grate
one cup to three one cup
and add three cups boiling water
and then you dissolve that you can also
put it on the stove and dissolve it all
and that's a liquid soap
you can keep that in a bottle that's
your liquid soap
and then you have your neem oil and now
if you want to make a pesticide out of
it
you take two parts
neem oil and one part
liquid soap so you can take
let's say two tablespoons of neem oil
and one tablespoon of your liquid soap
and you
mix those two together
then you take of that three teaspoons
this mixture it must be nice and
homogenized the oil must be all
homogenized with the soap
it becomes sort of whitish then you take
in american language one gallon
of water four and a half litres
of water and you add three teaspoons
full of this mixture
and that's your spray it will prevent
fungus but if you have serious fungus
then
you have to get rid of the fungus with a
copper spray
but if you regularly spray
with this neem oil spray then you will
keep the pests away
and you will also keep fungus away so
it's a beautiful thing
to use anyway so that's what some of our
stuff looked like
i'm sure you can get them bigger we had
one cucumber which was one meter tall it
was
was a heirloom seed japanese long
what an amazing cucumber a little bit
prickly but
beautiful in taste it was about this
thick
and one meter long so it's like a tent
post anyway these are some of the things
you can be doing
and some of the projects produce we
produced and
we dried basil leaves and this is what
organic farming will do
you will get amazing results you can get
huge leaks huge and the interesting
thing is
you know if you grow leaks for example
don't just
rip them out cut them off
and it grows back and leave that the
root stump in the ground it'll grow back
and letters will do the same won't be as
great as the first time but leeks work
pretty well
they should work well and you can grow
great pumpkins and this is the kind of
produce that you want but you want it
organic
and you want it in your home so
bottom line if you can secure yourselves
a piece of land
in the country to get out of the cities
with a little piece of land
and start playing around with organic
farming
and to keep yourself going while you
wait for your first crop
and you will have problems things will
go wrong but that's part of life it's
part of the fun
just start all over again uh
you will have a mole and you will have a
cutworm and you will have this and you
will have
that and you will have a grasshopper
but god is good yes you will still get
what you need
then start doing that and to keep
yourself going as i said
start with the microgreens and start
with sprouting in your house
and god'll bless as you invest in that
kind of
activity thank you walter i think we've
covered
quite a few different subjects and
questions
i'll close with the word of prayer
absolutely
hello every father thank you so much for
bringing us together and having
discussion and also thank you
for giving us such wonderful food that
we can
carry on and live the way you want us to
live
help us in these times that we can
discern what we should do and when we
should do it
and bring us back together and bless
everybody that watch this in jesus name
amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you